c'est à l'extérieur que sylvie se vend
montel tête de liste de tous pour
villepreux a choisi de mener sa campagne
élu depuis 12 ans elle s'est entourée
d'une équipe représentant tous les
quartiers de la ville voilà pourquoi
elle a choisi ce mode d'action pour
aller à la rencontre des habitants et
ses balades urbaines
c'est très novateur concept ça ne s'est
jamais fait à villepreux et dans
quasiment qu'une ville des yvelines à
part une ou deux et donc le concept de
dalé in situ sur le terrain des horaires
précis à la rencontre des villes projets
des divines provient ça a vraiment du
sens moi aussi parfois c'est gentil
monsieur c'est une bonne idée si ce sera
l'occasion de donner des des idées sur
les les améliorations à apporter dans le
quartier parmi les grands thèmes du
programme de sylvie se vend mon tel est
la sécurité le cadre de vie le
développement durable et la proximité
avec les élus sur les charmes un bon
petit footing la marche forcée et puis
je les rencontre et elle a une grande
expérience souci de la ville je pense
que ça va être un deal à tiverny tous
pour villepreux est une liste sans
étiquette et ne bénéficient pas de
soutien de partis politiques
nous voulons être libres on veut pas que
dans deux ans trois ans nous disent
écoutez on vous a aidé en 2020 voilà
vous nous renvoie l'ascenseur d'autres
balades urbaines sont prévus le week-end
du 25 janvier
l'équipe de tous pour villepreux se
rendra notamment cartier du vieux
village et du prieuré ainsi que dans le
quartier du val joyeux